10억이라는 예를 들어서 한 달에 8
900 정도가 나와서 연간 1억
[음악]
이상에네 안녕하세요 오늘 인터뷰 하실
분은 저평가된 숙박 부동산을 개발
시공 우영 아까지 접목해 가지고 종합
솔루션을 제공하고 있는 유식의 김준
대표님 모셨습니다 안녕하세요
안녕하세요 송합니다 아마 그 더식 좀
모르시는 분들이 계실 거예요 그래서
좀 더 더휴식 회사에 대해서 좀 소개
좀 부탁드리겠습니다 저희 더 유식은
중소형 숙박 시설 소위 말하는 모텔
시장에서 기본적으로는 회사에서 직접
매입해서 개발도 하고요 숙박업을
운영하시는 우리 건물주분 께는 저희가
기획 설배 시공부터 실제로 위탁 운영
그다음에 it 솔루션 개발부터
5년까지 이루어지는지를 전부 다
서비스로 제공하고 있는 회사입니다
이렇게 더유 식에서 개발한 사례들을
좀 멀게 봤었는데 정말 요즘에 맞게
엄청 잘하시더라고요
감사합니다 너무 잘하시고 그리고 아마
이제 그 보시는 분들 중에 모텔이나
호텔을 가지고 계신 분들 그리고 이제
숙박업 투자에 관심 있는 분들은
도유식라는 회사를 통해서 진짜 나중에
좀 이렇게 정보라든가 이런 거
얻으시면 너무 좋을 거 같고요 일단은
오늘 좀 사례를 좀 몇 개 준비해
주셨는데네 음 보면은 이건 대전에
있던 이런 낡은 두 개를 저 예 두
개를 한꺼번에 매입을 해서 개발한
사례예요 아 매입가는 어느 정도
되네요 저희가 매입을 할 했던
당시에는 어쨌든 두 개가 각각
27.5억 28억 정도였고 예 두
개를 합해서 약 55.5 정도에
매입을 해서 리모델링을 오른쪽 사진과
같이 했죠 우리가 만드는 숙박 시설의
타겟들을 보통 2 30대 미혼
커플들이 이 대부분이고 외관에
화려함에 이끌려 들어오는 워크인
고객은 10년 15년 전 얘기예요
지금은 연자와 여대와 같은 아주
훌륭한 플랫폼 기업들이이 시장에서
자들 잡고 있기 때문에 이제 그런
플랫폼을 통해서 들어오는 경우가 많고
저희도 70% 이상 예약
고객이거나네 저희는 뭐 그리고 예약이
아니더라도 사실상 이미 알고 온
재방문 고객이 굉장히 많습니다
예전에는 모텔이란 것들이 그 단순하게
싸게 하루 자고 가는 사업이었지만
지금은 특히 코로나 때 많이
바뀌었어요 전혀 매출이 들지 않고
굉장히 잘 됐거든요 왜냐면이 친구들이
갈 데가 없으니까 오히려 모든 소비
이안에서 하는 거예요 영화도 여기서
보고 노래도 여기서 불고 게임도
여기서 하고 쓸데없는 지출을 줄이고과
투자가 안 되는 쪽으로 최대한
심플하게 기획을 하되 매출에는 타격이
없는 그런 기획들을 주로 하고
있습니다 요거는 한번 봐서 었어요 저
그때 홍대에 갔다가 한번 봤는데 네네
좌측에 있던이 호텔이었던게 낡은
호텔이었는데 이렇게 이제 리모 두링
하신 거고네네 이게 오른쪽 사진이
저희가 무슨 막 분양 사진 찍으려고이
키워 놓은게 아니에요 지금 분양한
것도 아니고 실제 사진이거든요 그니까
되게 운이 좋게 우뚝 소사 했어요
근데 이거는 그렇게까지 객실이 많지
않거든요 레도 있께 어 실제로 호텔을
처음 해보시는 분이었고 호텔 처음 해
보시지만 사실 홍대이 정도에 건물을
갖고 있는 분은 굉장한 자산입니다 예
실제로 이제 제조업에서 굉장히 성공을
하셔서이 은퇴하시고이 업장을 운영을
하고 계셨는데 한 1억이 넘는 매출을
내고 계시다가 코로나의 직격탄을 받고
매출이 거의 70% 이상 떨어졌었어요
그러니까 대부분 다 이제 외국인이었던
그렇죠 그래서 저희가 21년도 이거를
매입을 할 때는 매도인은 거의 운영
적재가 매월 뭐 몇 천만 원씩 적자를
내고 계셨고 사실상 문을는게 유리한
상황이었는데 직원들이 있으니까 또
굉장히 좋은 분이어서 책임감은
있으시고이 전하고 계신 상황에서
저희가 매입을 했고 사실 그 시점에
부동산 경기 청
반대였어요을 하던 그죠 그러다 보니까
저희도 시행사와 경쟁을 했어요 아
시행사들이이 지역의 땅을 계속 이렇게
제안을 했는데 저희가 시행사가 제안한
보다 싸게 샀어요 더덕을 더 싸게
아주 예쁘진 않지만 트렌디하지 않지만
튼튼하게 잘 지어진 건물이었고 저희가
큰 외부에는 역시나 큰 돈을 들지
않았고 객실은 많이 좀 고치긴
했습니다 코로나 때도 국내 고객들만
대상으로 어 매출을 한 3 4천 정도
그전에 나왔던 걸로 제가 들었었는데
저희는 거기서 한 여섯 배 정도
매출이 올랐고 여섯
배요네 민감한 짐은 해도
돼요 대표님이
하시면 이거 일단 매입가는 한 제가
알고기 한 60억 원대 매입 하셨
매입가가 이게 78억 이었어요 78억
그러면은 한 70억 원대 사서
리모델링 비용까지 드리면 거의 뭐 한
90억네 90억 중반 정도 었는데
지금 여기서 나오는 매출 뭐 비용
이런 거 다 제외하고
수위대 민감하지 그거군요
매출 연동한 월세를 받는 개념 으로
아 대이 되어 있어요 근데 지금이
업장 건물 튜브는 에코티 한 20억
정도 넣으셨고 어 그 리모델링
비용까지 다 네네 굉장히 사실
합리적임네 에코티 수익률은 이분
입장에서 20% 이상 나고 있죠 지금
또 만드셨 요수리 우리 천안 아닉
요칸 이고요 여기는 굉장히 그냥
애초에 메가도 굉장히 저렴하고 저희가
시험삼아 한번 해봤던 어차피 워크인
고에 있을 수가 없기 때문에네 모던한
느낌은 도저히 예산으로는 충족이 안
되니 오히려 레트로로 가자 해서 좀
세게 넣었고 지금은 실제로 사진
촬영하고 모델분들이 엄청 많이 오세요
아 그래 또 일반적인 숙박 고객들도
많이 오십니다 어 이건 어디서 많이
온 거 같은데 그 바로 이면에 있는
거 아니에요 맞아요 태원 역에서 아
여기도 이제제 오픈이 작년
말이었으니까 코로나 리오프닝 후에
이태원 상권이 점점 회복이 되면서
살아나는 시점에 딱 오픈을 했고 아은
뭐 첫달부터 굉장히 잘 나오고
있습니다 사실 사례들이 더 많거든요
근데 일단 시간 관계에서 여기까지만
보고 더 이렇게
좀 민감한 질문을 좀
더이 아마 이제 실질적으로 살려고
하시는 분들이 꽤 있을 것 같아요
서울 지역에는 사실 좀 쉽지 않을 거
같고 만약에 뭐 수도권이나 아니면
지방에 진짜 내가 이런 걸 사 가지고
투자하고 싶다 라고 하면 최소 한
실투자금은 한 어느 정도음 너무
천차만별이지만 일반적으로 3 40개
정도의 객실이 있다고 했을 때 에코티
사이즈가 10억대 중반 결국 10에서
20억 사이가 거의 대부분이에요 그
리모델링 비용까지 거 그렇죠 대출을
빼고 나머지 그래서 뭐 그런 것도
궁금해할 거 같아요 모텔이나 호텔이
개발 완료된 다음에 이제 수익률이
어느 정도 되 매각 차익은 일단 좀
외로 하고요 네네 기본적으로 너무
다양하지만 어쨌든 저희 내부 기준은
운영 기간에 두 자리수가 10억이라는
예를 들어서 한 달에 8 900
정도가 나와서 연간 1억 이상의
프로젝트 단에서는 가져갈 수 있다요
정도가 저희가 기본적으로 타겟하는
숫자입니다 아 그리고 만약에 이제
위탁 운영을 맡기는 경우에는 좀 어떤
방식으로 좀 진행되는지 대부분의
투자자분들 먼저 말씀드리면
투자자분들은 너네가 알아서 해 줘
너네가 다 해 줘 고용부 모든 걸 다
해 줘 수수료 계약으로 이루어지는
경우가 대부분입니다 가끔 고정 임차
계약도 있기는 한데 그거는 이제
저희가 잘 판단을 해서 많은 경우에는
수수료가 투자자도 유리하죠 어차피
이게 본업이 분들은 어 나는 운영은
내가 그래도 할 거야 내가 이것도 안
하면 나는 어 병날 것 같아 이런
분들도 계세요 그러면은 저희가 인력
세팅 마케팅 채널 판매 채널 세팅
그다음에 운영 대행 런 구조로 갑니다
본인이 실제 운영 주체인 하지만
저희는 오히려 그분이네 출을 내고
저희가 피를 받는 그리고 마지막으로
이런 숙박 부동산 투자에 관심 있는
분들이 계실 거 같아요 그분들한테 좀
이렇게 해주고 싶은 말이 있으실까요
거의 자산가들의 시장으로
바뀌었잖아요네 그러다 보니까 뭐 내가
코티 몇도 가지고는 강남에 꼬마 빌딩
엄두도 못내고 그렇다고 지방 걸
사자이 대표님도 말씀하시듯이 금성 예
황금성에 떨어지고 이런 분들이 실제로
저회사 많이 찾아오시 어렵습니다
솔직히 좀 제 말 고 그냥 아이 나
못 해먹겠다 하시는 분들 있을 수
있는데 단순하게 어떤 숫자 원가 대비
수만 보고 접근하셨습니다 결론적으로는
매각에서 어려움을 겪고 실패하고 본이
하는게 장기 투자로 이어지는 경우가
너무 많아서 그런 것들 좀 주의하시면
좋을 것 같습니다 이게 사실 뭐
운영해 가지고 운영 수입 가는 것도
중요하지만 사실 부동산을 사는
거잖아요 부동산 가치가 사실 올라야
되는 부분이 제 큰데 그거를 더
유식이 되게 잘하는 거 같아요 그냥
운영하는 업체랑은 조금 저는 다르다고
많이 느끼고 있거든요
감사합니다네 네 어 일단 오늘 좀
많은 얘기를 좀 나눠봤는데 좀 숙박
부동산에 관해서 좀 관심 있으신 분
계시면 더시 연락을 해 가지고 좀
이렇게 문의를 하거나 예 그러면 좋을
것 같습니다 오늘 영상은 여기까지
하고요 다음 시간에도 뵙도록
하겠습니다 감사합니다
감사합니다